nous y sommes chers collègues nous
abordons donc ce fameux article 7 cœur
de l'injustice et de la brutalité de
cette réforme nous entamons l'étude de
cet article après que des millions de
Françaises et Français viennent de
manifester contre cette réforme afin
d'avoir droit à une retraite descente à
un âge décent pour rappel plus de 75%
des Français et Françaises sont contre
cette réforme ça a été rappelé par
d'autres parlementaires vous avez aussi
au sein de votre propre électorat ou les
Français sont massivement contre cette
réforme et vous le disent constamment
des millions et des millions de Français
françaises manifestent et vous faites ce
soir au moment où on aborde cet article
comme si de rien n'était à l'image du
ministre Dupond-Moretti vous faites un
bras d'honneur au pas au peuple français
qui pourtant pacifiquement
manifeste contre cette réforme de plus
en plus nombreux imaginez la violence
que vous renvoyez au peuple français par
votre indifférence par rapport à ce
qu'ils expriment constamment dans la rue
imaginez la violence que cela peut avoir
sur des gens qui vont devoir travailler
2 ans de plus alors qu'ils font des
métiers pénibles difficiles ces gens qui
sont les indispensables de notre pays
c'est eux que vous brutalisez vous
pourritaliser le peuple français en
brutalisant les essentiels de ce pays on
ne peut pas gouverner contre le peuple
nous sommes ici pour les représenter
c'est un vrai problème démocratique de
vouloir absolument brutalement imposer
une réforme par des procédures qui
limitent le temps de nos débats qui
auraient mérité justement un débat
beaucoup plus long sur le fond quand on
touche un sujet aussi fondamental qui
touche notre pack de social qui touche
plusieurs générations nous devons
prendre le temps de pouvoir en débattre
c'est pas la voix que vous avez choisie
vous-même parlementaire de droite vous
devez vous élever contre ça vous avez
dit vous sortez vous au pouvoir vous
feriez beaucoup plus de concertation
bâtiments au gouvernement c'est pas ce
qu'ils ont fait donc ce que nous
demandons c'est le retrait de cet
artiste et le retrait de cette réponse
[Musique]